a brand new documentary series on Prince
Harry and Megan just dropped overnight
and it's the first three episodes on
Netflix the rest of the series will be
released next week joining us now is
Royal contributor that's Roy Anika She's
Royal editor of London Sun Times Roya
good morning to you most people in this
country haven't seen it yet but I know
you've seen all three episodes what's
your reaction
well good morning Gail
um look I think my first takeaway is
there's no excuse me there's no killer
blow in this but we do have a much
greater understanding now of the
challenges that Harry and Megan faced
and how difficult they felt their life
was within the royal family the things
that stood out for me were there a
couple of really pointed jives at
William
um Harry mentioned that he felt his
experience was Men in the family married
women who fit the mold rather than who
they were destined to be with that would
be very hard for William to hear and
certainly there is a there are some
claims from Harry and Megan that they
did not feel supported and Megan had a
much harder time than Kate
but we have you know it's good to hear
from them we know how they felt and I
think everyone's on 10 Turks for the
next three episodes
yeah they said that they wanted it to be
their love story that people will get to
see who they are what they are and how
this all came to be do you think people
will in the UK will soften to that
we definitely you know we there's much
more deep there are a lot of intimate
moments that are recorded on Megan's
phone we you know we hear a lot more
about how they first met on social media
interestingly and then were set up on a
blind date
um yeah there are some really sweet
moments we hear about the proposal um
actually we actually see Megan on the
phone to one of her friends as Harry's
uh proposing to her so there's a lot
more intimacy um that we haven't seen
before they're opening up a lot of their
lives
um will people here react to that I
think people might raise an eyebrow that
so many intimate moments have been
shared but this was about their love
story and we definitely know more about
that now
all right Roy Anika I have to tell you I
can't wait to see it thank you very much